- Ist das die letzte?
- Ja.
- Hilfst du mir?
- Ich muss noch ein
paar Getränke servieren.
Die Gäste an Tisch drei haben schon
bestellt, als du in der Küche warst.
- Kein Problem,
das krieg' ich auch alleine hin.
Hi, Nico! Danke schön.
- Hey!
- Bitte schön.
Was macht ihr?
- Was meinst du?
- Die Kisten.
- Ach so.
Ähm, wir liefern die Lebensmittel,
die am Wochenende übrig geblieben sind,
an soziale Institutionen,
die sie gebrauchen können.
- Cool.
- Und wo kommst du jetzt her?
- Ich komme gerade von
der Agentur für Arbeit.
Ich will ja bald
meine Ausbildung beginnen.
- Bei Yara?
- Mein spanischer Abschluss
ist anerkannt worden.
- Echt? Super! Freust du dich?
- Ja, sehr!
Als ich klein war, hab' ich
auch schon gerne Sachen repariert
und bald verdien' ich damit Geld.
- Und wenn es irgendwann einmal langweilig
wird, machst du einfach eine Umschulung.
- Hm? Umschulung?
- Ja. Du lernst etwas Neues.
Tarek und ich haben eine
Umschulung gemacht,
als wir das Restaurant eröffnet haben.
- Ich helf' dir!
- Okay.
Oh! Och, Nico.